there is plenty of daylight between the
main candidates running for Mexico's
presidency in this summer's election but
not when it comes to president Trump our
national correspondent William la
jeunesse tells us tonight from Los
Angeles the American leader is one thing
most Mexicans can surely agree on the
race for Mexico's next president
features three very different candidates
the ruling party the reformer and the ex
radical manuel lopez obrador
is the Bernie Sanders of Mexico a hard
left populist known for his firebrand
style and socialist bite policies known
by his initials
AM L o obrador placed second in the last
two presidential elections but refused
to concede he promises to break up
corporate monopolies and use the United
Nations to stop president Trump's
proposed border wall they want somebody
who will stand up and and and represent
Mexico more independently and more
forcefully obradors main challengers
Ricardo Anaya a 38 year old reformer
running with support from the left and
right Anaya proposes a universal basic
income about five hundred and fifty
dollars a year paid for by eliminating
welfare he would lead Mexico's first
coalition government I think there's an
appetite in Mexico for going for new
people from the establishment comes Jose
Antonio Meade with a master's from Yale
and four previous cabinet level jobs
meet is experienced but carries the
burden of the unpopular outgoing
Institutional Revolutionary Party or
free which is seen as corrupt and
ineffective in stopping cartel violence
he's not a game changer in that sense of
being able to represent a new current
inside the PRI according to the latest
poll the ex radical Obrador leads Anaya
by nine and Mead by twenty while over
door is the favorite he is running at a
party he created it will not have the
benefit of down ticket support on the
other hand he is in hampered by their
reputations of corruption John William
la jeunesse thanks